tomorrow marks the 50th anniversary of
the Stonewall riots here in New York
City which served as a catalyst for the
gay rights movement in our series issues
that matter we take a look this morning
at the process of the LGBTQ community is
made and the challenges that still
persist a recent survey by The Trevor
Project reveals nearly one in five LGBTQ
young people attempted suicide in the
last year for more than two decades The
Trevor Project has worked to end this
long-running crisis it offers emergency
counseling by phone text and chat more
than 200,000 calls and messages come in
every year that's a lot of people
calling a meet paly a CEO and executive
director of The Trevor Project and joins
us at the table good to see you good to
see you you all have just released a
survey to really put things in
perspective and while there has been
some progress made there still as you
pointed a lot of work to be done what
concerns you most of mean I think what
concerns me most is still the
discrimination and the sense of
isolation that so many LGBTQ young
people feel across the country the
survey you mentioned that we just
released found that 39% of LGBTQ youth
seriously considered suicide in the past
year that is heartbreaking and
unacceptable in 2019 and shows how much
work we have to do to make sure every
young person feels loved and supported
and sometimes you are on the phone you
were on the phone answering when people
call in what are you hearing what are
they saying to you yeah I've been a
volunteer for eight years and a lot of
what we hear from young people is this
sense of fear of what will happen if
they ever reveal to someone who they
really are and who they really love and
they're scared of coming out to their
parents or in schools and so we let them
know that there may be people and their
community they don't accept that what do
you what advice do you give parents who
have kids in this position to help them
the most important thing is to come from
a place of love and we give a lot of
advice on specifically how to respond
into support but if you come from a
place of love if you come from place of
this is my child and I love them no
matter what and I will support them it's
very hard to go wrong if that's your
core focus on this point of a place of
love when you look at the long-term
trends from Stonewall to now it's
definitely a story of progress and
increases in tolerance but I was caught
by surprised by the cover of USA Today
we
has a study from GLAAD and Harris
showing that young people are actually
displaying less tolerance in some
respects are we at risk here at 50 years
from Stonewall of moving in the wrong
direction there's been a lot of progress
but we definitely are at risk those
rights were hard fought and there has
been a backslide in many regards we have
seen since the in particular the
presidential election in 2016 the day
after the 2016 presidential election our
call volume at the Trevor Project more
than doubled in a 24 hour period of time
when the president tweeted the
transgender people would be banned from
the military we saw trans and non-binary
youth reaching out to us in record
numbers because words really matter I
think we talked a lot about the policies
policies and laws protect people but
when people in positions of power use
hateful words young people hear that and
it makes them feel like they are less
than are not deserving of love and rest
of us understand why I meet in 2019
people still feel alone because so many
people have spoken out publicly and very
proud of their orientation but you said
not everybody sees that message not
everyone sees that message and I think
we have to remember there are young
people across the country if you're a
young trans person in rural North Dakota
you might see on TV that there's a lot
of acceptance but then you look around
your community if you don't see any
openly LGBTQ people if your faith
community is not supporting you if your
school is not allowing you to use the
restroom that corresponds with your
gender identity you're gonna feel like
people won't accept you and that can
lead to that sense of isolation and
feelings of wanting to kill yourself
conversion therapy is still something in
2019 totally that surprised me I think a
lot of people don't realize that
conversion therapy which is the
completely discredited and dangerous
practice of trying to forcibly change
your sexual orientation or gender
identity it is still legal in 32 states
in the country we estimate there are
more than 700,000 people who have
undergone conversion therapy in this
country and so we are working really
hard and we also know that when you
undergo conversion therapy it puts you
at much higher risk of suicide so we
need to stop that in every state in this
country so much work to be done still
with despite all the progress I made
paly thank you so much for being with us
this morning